non
résidente madame la ministre mes chers
collègues depuis 2010 7 les sept agences
de
des comités de bassin qui financent une
part de plus en plus importante des
politiques environnementales
et ce même bien au delà de leur
compétence propre agence française de la
biodiversité parcs nationaux et j'en
passe plutôt que d'accorder à ces
opérateurs des crédits propres le
gouvernement puise dans le budget des
agences de l'eau lui même constituée par
des redevances payées par tous les
usagers ainsi elles financent
actuellement près de la moitié des
politiques de biodiversité mais cela ne
s'arrête pas là vous avez institué un
plafond mordant autrement dit un seuil
fixé en 2010 9 2 1 milliards d'euros au
delà duquel les recettes perçues par les
agences vont directement dans le budget
général de l'état et ce alors même qu'un
rapport parlementaire mené par votre
propre majorité déclare que les agences
de l'eau ont besoin de 400 millions
d'euros de plus par an afin de mener à
bien leur mission ledit rapport rappelle
que les agences sont des acteurs
essentiels de la préservation de l'eau
elle-même ou financent des actions de
dépollution d'entretien de réseau de
restauration des rivières
ce plafond mordant vient ici imposer une
règle budgétaire totalement anachronique
ne prenons pas la mesure des
problématiques de notre temps et des
problématiques
il n'en manque pas multiplication des
inondations et des sécheresses pour un
ré faction des ressources en eau
élévation du niveau de la mer causés par
le dérèglement climatique sont tout
autant de sujets qui vont nécessiter des
actions de grande ampleur d'ici la fin
du siècle les agences de l'eau prévoit
une baisse de 10 à 50 % du débit
d'étiage des grands fleuves et de 10 à
30 % des nappes phréatiques
ce qui entraînera une plus grande
concentration des polluants dans les
rivières la question madame la ministre
est la suivante en organisant par le
biais du plafond mordant l'attrition des
finances des agences de l'eau ne nous
éloignons nous pas du modèle
décentralisé de gestion de l'eau par les
agences et les comités de bassin et de
fait aux principes de l'eau et l'eau